Susy Cruz has made her dream come true
she's converted an old VW t3 into a
camper now she can travel wherever and
whenever she likes she did all the work
herself from the furnishings to the
paneling the vehicle is equipped with
two batteries and a voltage transformer
she paid an expert to check all the
technology because she didn't want
anything to go wrong
[Music]
the caravan salon in Dusseldorf is
currently showing lots of different
campers sales of campers have really
jumped over the last year nearly 14%
if you're on a budget you may want to
check out the compact Adria action it
sleeps four and costs about sixteen
thousand euros in Germany there's a
kitchen in the rear and a spacious
bathroom complete with a sink and a
shower
[Music]
a pullout Grill is available as an
option
[Music]
the humor company has been building
campers for 60 years
and mobile homes since 1972
Malea dono has devoted her life to
caravans and hasn't missed a caravan
salon for 55 years she remembers what it
was like in the early days it's Etsy
cousin Maria says the industry has made
a lot of progress over the years the
first campers her marveled had no
refrigerators or even heating to keep
food cold you cut a hole in the camper
floor and hang a covered aluminum tub
down there that was a refrigerator
thankfully those days are over
Maria says her mom has been using foam
insulation in its vehicles since 1979
the quality of the insulation has
improved since then these days they use
a self-contained system that includes
the windows and the skylight the
insulation is extremely durable
we don't use wood in the walls and the
insulation is equivalent to that of an
80 centimeter thick brick wall
centimeter points agrammatism as soon
this exhibition features motorhomes for
the 2018 model year one of the most
luxurious models is humours B Class SL
it's just under 8 meters long and 3
meters tall and it can sleep up to five
people SLC stands for superlight chassis
which weighs four point five tonnes
[Music]
the industry has embraced all-electric
technology like this a home from dead
laughs the prototype is based on the
chassis of the IVA kodály electric
[Music]
Detlef spokesman Alexander Leopold
predicts that this technology will
spread quickly through the industry
that's why the company wanted to get an
early start
it's presenting a prototype version
today but there's a long way to go
before it can start mass producing these
vehicles see of item big Florence
business concept and it's a negotiating
talk assignment the Escarra bond from
green cap technologies is attracting a
lot of attention this is a prototype
version of this futuristic mobile home
[Music]
it can run on wind or solar power the
home which weighs 2.5 tons can rotate on
a rail around its vertical axis to make
optimal use of available sunlight the s
carbons interior features a kitchen with
a lot of counter space there's also a
bathroom with a separate shower area
when the home is folded up it's just 2.5
meters wide and can be easily towed by
another vehicle
Volkswagen utility vehicles unveiled its
new prototype the California XXL at the
exhibition it's based on the design of
the VW crafter CW's account Schultz says
that they decided early on to keep the
California spirit in the new class of
vehicles he says on test drives of the
crafter industry colleagues would ask
when are you going to do a California
that's based on the crafter and that's
how VW came up with the idea for the
vehicle that we see here today it's a
concept vehicle Ghanim in decent fat
Sakyong jettison concept fat sack we
double use your cake fold points out
that the California XXL has five
different living areas in a relatively
small space here at the back the bed
covers the width of the vehicle it's 2
meters long in the rear lounge there's
an LED projection TV your pools of these
panels here to show us the shower area
christian silence eat what you douche
manifold in an excellent green shower
tank a nice dream of to litigate a
comfortable toilet and a wash basin that
folds down
it's not clear yet when the first
California XXL will hit the market or
how much it will cost meanwhile Suzy
starts off on a new adventure
she's found the perfect vacation road
vehicle
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she says that right now she's just happy
to cook and surf but if you'd rather
have a store-bought camper or mobile
home then build it yourself
the folks at caravan salon will be happy
to show you around
[Music]